penelope uh tell us about you so you
went to sit with it you too you went to
see you too in concert yeah many times
yes i love them of course yes now did
they invite you on stage
yes
i was terrified but bono is our friend
for many many years and we cannot say no
to him and i i was more nervous than
ever on that stage
i thought i was going to ruin the whole
thing i don't know why i
well
maybe you did uh something picture we've
got a picture of you coming up on the
stage there you are up on stage lovely
but now in terms of you know i'd like to
take a picture of the performance uh
let's have a look at this next uh
picture i mean that
is a picture i mean
that's that's going to be distracting no
you know what happened is that that what
i was taping was shown live on the stage
so that's what bono asked me to do so i
was just following his order yeah right
okay and i was trying to be really
creative because everyone was seeing in
the big screen in the huge screen where
i was filming and i almost crashed into
the edge twice and i really thought i
was gonna ruin that performance
[Music]